YOU RFID
E   IN THE MEANTIME, WE HAVEOTHT
TRAIL.
THS MEAN BOOST
PRIMARY CANDIDATE INO.
BUT MOSTFO 2020.
I SHOULD HAVE  2022  OHIO. GROWC
THIS MORNING, TTY
HIS VIEW OF THE SPECTACLE.WING .
THATISKNOW PSAY,
THEY BELIEVE IN THBI
LIE E CASEK
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THA I
D MBT.IT IINE.ELECTIOVER.
IT WAS FAIR.
>> FORD
N CONGRESS
SHOW.
DO YOU THINK ABOUT SENATO
RDHI
JUST ENTME NOWHERE.
YOU CONTRAHA
ET.
CLEARL  FROTRUMP'S
MIAN PANDEMIC E ELECTION
WH
>> I HOPE HE'S.
LF PEOPLE THAT
T ARAT
ME FOR JUST TELLING TH
WHICH USEDBAR.
THAT REALLY ULY BELIEVDONALD TRS
ES
ALL HIS SAW YESAS A
F A LOSER ENT.
HE'S THE FIRST TLO
RE-EION IN DECADES
D I DON'T KNOW WHY FOLKS
A US
THEYID
IN ABOUT THE ATE RUNNING GWYNET
ANTHONY GOEZ, WHIS
, ANTHONY E GUY RUNNING T HIM.DH
NEORLD PEAN NOITS  LEVEL
AND THEN HE WENTO OLD T NOGO
NT
E M IS PEOPLEV
IS REALLY THERE'S ENOUGHE THAT
HTE HE'LL BE PRESIDENT AGAIN ISP
TAND YET THEY
STENT.
CONGRESSMAN,ANT HE
NT ABOUT ELECTION
LAWS.>>ONHOLD THEM INWHEN THEY R
ATG OTHERS TO .REG IT'S TRUE.
TH HTY TEAD .
THEMN AYT EDT IS VERY TGH T AT
>> YOU HAVE OBVISLON R
UTSPOKEN
DO YOU SHARE THAT SAMEMBERS OF T
KIND OF,OUNO BURY THEIR
HEAD A LITTLE BIR TH
ALONIGAUSE ALLY DIFFICULT TSTANE
TRUTHFUL WHE E
A DOT,
WE HAV OUR
NS.OR
DI SOME IF NOBODY IS
TAKIR D OPLE ATA WAY,
TRULY ISNO CT ANYTBUT WH SAW LA
ELTOLEE  HEAR PEOP TELLING
THEM OTHERWISE.
E AND LIZ CHEN
IF IT IS JUSZE US AND Y 'RTHND R
RI BUT WE'RE TELLING THE IT IS
MEMBER OF SS
OFFICIALS, SAYG.
JOE BIDEN WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT
RE-ELEN.QUG IT WASLE
THAT'S REALLEADANGEROUS.
>>
INSURRECONHE LIES ST
THE LIES TTHR ALWI
BLAME.AVA GRSPCHHE SAID DO
BLAME.
ET CERWE KNOW THAT HE HAD HA
ABOUT A WEEK.
AND THENE WENTTOR-ST ARORNY RAIS
D D PUT THEM DONALD TRUMP ANRES
HIM POLITICALLY.
PRIOR TOM, McCARTHY WAS DOING
THMcCONNELL,HOIS TRU
YOU TABOUT
IMBED OF
THE SECOND KEVIN WENT TOLAGO,  .
, YOLDBC THAT YOU
N'. RUNWHO DON'T LIKE THAT YOU'?
CONTMUCH.WE DON'
BEHIND THE SCENES U RECOE AT YOR
DOING.
YOU I CONSIDER
HIM  OF MINE.
ARE YOU GOING TO TELL MIS SOMTA
?ENYING AT JANUARY 6 W WHA
OOK, IS HE STILL A FRIEND?
MONTHS.
>> HAVE YOU REACHED OUT TO
SENTEN NO.TIME.THAT
HIM.S THE, RIGHT? GO
I'LCO T THE A HOPHE
DOES,
HIM ANHE>> I WTO REVISIT SOMETH.
LISTEN.
>>VE ON
>>E SHOU
COMMITTEE.
>> ANDI WORKED HARD AY ULD WOR
PROMFICANCE?
YOUAN THE
BECAUSE SHE WAS STRIPPEDIT NGL
WITH CONSPIRACEORIES
AND  B
SHE'S DONE AD JO MOUS.
ONS.IF
I WOULDER CAN IT.
I WAO
I WANT TO PURSUE LEADS.
BUT ATS EN  ASKEDI'M CERTAIN KEY
PU O.
I'LL CTINUE TORYT TO
THE TRUT.Y QUICKLY, BEFOR GET
TO TG
ON BEHALOFN MILITARY
OR CAME OU
THATTH
HA BARE THE T LIES.
RUNOFF. McCONNEL UT
WHAT IS YOURIN.
AVA MESSAGE
FOTCH ON THAT.OW THEAS WITTHE RU
IN THOLEON I THINK REPUBLICA
S BECAUSOFAL
TRUMP.
L BARR OUERBUT THE BOTTOM LIN T
START.
HEARD NYTHEMMILLIONS
>> YOU'RE WORKING VERYD EXPEDITS
AFGHAN SUPPOERSO . .
THIS IS MPORTANT MISSION FO
WHAT ITHAT OTHAT
EFFORT?
WE HEARDCOMMITTED TO
GEUT
THER TASK.SO0 OR,000 FS.E PP OUT
AFGHANISTAN IN A MONTHL WILL BE.
A  TRATO THALPS HAVE ALREADY BE
BTALIBAN AN B.
THIS IS NOT  DOWN ON